now here's the other thing about your
childhood i want to go into
you were a bowling uh almost a
professional bowler
right it's funny to say yeah it's weird
why is it when we hear bowling
we laugh is it is it hardly a sport in
the sense that anything you
you can eat pizza and smoke cigarettes
during can
actually be a sport but it is where did
you learn to bowl
it's you know my grandparents both my
parents were in a bowling center
and inadvertently half of my family was
all in that bowling center
and you start bowling when you're three
years old yeah yeah did you use the
bumpers or you were immediately
no i didn't have bumpers back then yeah
you're the tiger woods of bones
exactly so at three you start bowling
and it turns out you've got some sort of
ability for this
i guess yeah yeah and and you've you
bowl uh your average is what 225
yeah yeah oh my god i'm never going to a
bowling party with you
that's why i can't do that that game
almost put me in therapy
it did right because you became
competitive yeah yeah you can only
compete against yourself
so when you're 12 years old your
emotional intelligence
is pretty low right and i'm pulling
against you know 35 year olds that are
pro bowlers and were you on the pro
circuit not on a pro circuit as a sort
of like more of a
tournament circuit if you will yeah 12.
and then i would um
yeah i would bowl against him and again
it's you're bullying against your own
score
not going against their score right so
um i didn't have you know i would not
have the ability to be able to mostly
deal with
you know me not performing so when you
would lose a bowling match
i'd be kicking the ball or turn cursing
so what did it what what age did you
stop playing
bowling i stopped when i was probably
like 12. like 12.
i mean i might have bowled a few times
since then but not anymore
have you ever like when you're in
hollywood have you ever gone to a
bowling party
having fun and drinking beers and
farting
you know and then you shut up and you go
up and bowl like a 300 i'm like oh we're
gonna bowl we got a bowl yeah
i can't or have to scrap like you know
the pink sparkly one and just like kind
of roll it with one finger like you know
between my legs
and what is the trick to bowling is it
is it that um
constant practice or can you throw with
a spin and all that you've got to learn
all that right
yeah yeah it's just mechanics and does
it matter it's like swinging a baseball
bat or tennis racket
and can you tell if if if a bowling
alley is oiled a certain way
yeah i'm left i'm left-handed yeah and
i'm left-handed too so the it's a little
bit more consistent on the left-hand
side of the lanes
maybe you should at this point in your
career start concentrating on bowling
again like do a whole reversal now
you know those actors who like all of a
sudden they become boxers maybe you
should just devote yourself to bowling
at this point
yeah that would be awesome jeremy renner
has retired from acting and
now a professional bowler to be just
awesome
you